pth council conference here in
luxembourg you've presented the early
findings of a unique new study tell us
what some of the highlights were of that
broadband for all is a big topic at this
event and it's been a big topic at this
event for
many uh iterations
we
think
and we want to demonstrate through the
analysis
that the prevailing model to
extend broadband as further out into a
given country as possible
is not really working
and we think that there's
a better model that would require a lot
less public subsidies basically the
prevailing model is
a private operator says well this is how
far i'll go this is how far it's
profitable for me to go in terms of
fiber deployment
and then the government comes in and
says well i'll subsidize you to go
further
so that determines kind of a second
threshold and anything beyond that no
one really knows how it's going to be
addressed
we believe that instead if instead of
turning to a private operator to do that
we were looking at infrastructure
companies to do that
we could get most of that territory
covered in fact possibly more territory
covered than the subsidized
version of the prevailing model
without any subsidies
so
so are we saying if we see fdth as
purely infrastructure we'll get like
nationwide cover
there's some caveats because
in any geography there are a few
outliers that are so complicated to
connect that you do have to
consider alternative methods etc but
that should be five percent of the
territory not 25 percent of the
territory or 55 percent of the territory
depending on the cases
the other caveat is that
infrastructure requires
specific business model considerations
the investors are in it for the long
term and they want to have
certainty of
profitability and in order to do that
the prevailing regulatory model is
probably not
adapted because
price regulation is reviewed every three
years
and depending on
changes within the regulators
organizations or whatever you can have
pretty radical shifts
in price regulation and the types of
shareholders that will invest massively
in infrastructure are very unhappy with
that
and so
we believe that in order for
this model to work
you would also need to look at
asset-based regulation the way for
example that water and electricity are
currently regulated where what is capped
is not the price it's the amount of
profit that the operation can do and
that creates a virtual circle because
excess profit has to be reinvested which
means more infrastructure so it creates
this kind of dynamic where
deploying more infrastructure is an
integral part of the business model it's
not anything new in a sense so are you
confident it might happen
what do you think what do you think it
will take for people to look at this
business model
i think
first of all
policymakers need to understand
that they have been
they haven't been subsidizing more
broadband they've been subsidizing
companies that are not
well suited to deploy infrastructure so
that they could deploy infrastructure so
they have to understand that and they
have to understand
that it's a market structure issue
more than an inherent issue of fiber
fiber in and of itself is not expensive
because expensive
is
a definition of
you know a private market player saying
well this is too much and i can't do it
but that depends on who the market
player is so first of all they have to
realize that and second they need a
certain amount of political courage to
say
well
sure
existing players are happy with the
market structure but it's not delivering
what we need for our country and so it
has to change now the good news is in in
some previous analysis we looked at
the impact of structural separation for
shareholders of telecom companies and
actually that impact is massively
positive so
we're just at the very beginning of this
whole education piece but we believe
that
all of the parties actually have only
positives
in this consideration it's just that
because it's a big shift it's going to
take some time
well let's hope we get there thanks very
much for joining us you're welcome